joining us on the line is brand new
daily wire personality alison williams
so you may know allison's story in brief
because of course it was national news
last week she resigned from espn rather
than subjecting herself to being fired
by espn over their vaccine mandate
allison joins us online allison how are
you doing what's up buenos dias from
mexico i'm good i'm i'm in baja so life
is good right now
so for those who missed the story what
exactly happened to espn cause you were
there for a decade you were there for a
very long time you're doing sideline
reporting and then what sort of drove
the wedge uh the mandate i mean that was
what this all boiled down to and i i
kind of
just gets under my skin when i hear that
i quit i don't feel like i quit i feel
like i was forced to leave i mean the
the notion that i made a decision and
therefore it's my that's not a decision
i mean the decision between getting an
injection or keeping your job is not a
true decision right um so that that was
what it came down to i requested
accommodation i went through all the
necessary legal and hr steps to see if
there was a way i could work safely
without being a burden to the company
and they decided that that was not an
option um i had hosted virtually for
them in the past i thought maybe there'd
be some some role for me in that
capacity but they decided that there was
not and that if i did not get the
injection i could not be employed by the
company so allison
on a personal level obviously you
already had covid fairly early on and
and also you were trying to get pregnant
and you had questions about
covid injections and and and vaccines uh
for people who are attempting to get
pregnant and there's been you know cdc
says it's safe but the fact is the cdc's
been wrong before and there are a lot of
people who have questions about that
sort of stuff this is why it should be
an individual decision
they had nothing to say about the fact
that you already had natural immunity
no no that that does not matter at all
um in any of this which to me
just screams how illogical this all is
everything we know about unity going
back hundreds of years
is that natural immunity is far superior
and we're learning that as we go with
cope but right there's i think 60
studies out right now comparing natural
immunity to vaccinated immunity and
everything is showing that natural
immunity is superior it lasts longer and
so on and so forth but that was never
even a question i mean this was
literally just about compliance or not
you complied and you worked or you
didn't and and you didn't work um i did
have concerns i do have concerns in
relation to this vaccine look i
understand safe and effective safe and
effective right i understand that the
cdc says that it's safe for women um in
pregnancy that it doesn't impact
fertility
that's all based on what we know at this
time science changes research changes it
is so new no no um studies were done in
regards to fertility there were no
pregnant women involved in the clinical
trials that means the first person that
got this injection after the emergency
use authorization that was pregnant was
the first test subject um that for me is
just not enough to take the risk right
like this is a risk benefit analysis
everything we do in life has risks and
you have to weigh it against the benefit
for me having had covert benefit pretty
nil to getting this injection risk even
if it's 0.1
why take that why jeopardize having a
child when i want even if it just delays
it a few months i don't want to take
that risk there isn't a benefit to
outweigh the risks for me when it comes
to getting this so allison obviously i'm
sure you're still speaking with friends
who are at espn what's been the general
uh tenor of the of the situation over at
espn how many people are just fine with
the vaccine mandate and how many people
over there that you're talking to
are upset with this sort of stuff coming
from espn which again is an increasingly
woke territory just generally i think
it's a bit mixed ben to be honest
everybody that's reached out has been
beyond supportive people that i was
actually surprised to hear from i knew
how they felt about the vaccine i knew
how they
leaned politically and i was really
surprised how many people reached out
and just said we support you we're sorry
you're in this position we respect your
decision and some of them would even say
look i don't necessarily agree but i
understand why you're making the
decision you are and isn't what we all
ultimately want like i don't expect them
to say you're doing the right thing and
i 100 support you but the fact that you
can respect somebody making a different
decision than you that's what this is
all about and that's what's being lost
right now with the divide but i also
don't want to kid myself ben like
there's people that i haven't heard from
and their silence speaks volumes and
they are people who have been there for
me throughout every step of my career
and who have been incredibly supportive
and who i know
know what is going on and haven't said
anything and i think that speaks volumes
as well but i will say i have been
overwhelmed with support from um people
who are on air uh people who have worked
behind the scenes people who i've never
even met
that have reached out and said hey i i
was at espn2 or i'm here now and uh the
other part of this that i think
i think bothers me more than anything is
the people that reached out and said i
didn't want to get it and i got it to
keep my job and i'm pulling for you and
um that kind of breaks my heart because
i know how
how probably powerless and helpless they
felt in making the decision that they
didn't want to make uh to keep their job
and provide for their families and
that's that's what this is about this
should not be a position anybody in
america is in uh allison their loss is
our gain obviously you're going to be
working with us now we're really excited
to be to be doing that and you're going
to be taking on some of the
controversial topics in the sporting
world i can talk a little bit about the
kind of stuff that you'd like to cover
first of all thank you because i'm so
excited and i'm so excited we were able
to move quickly at this because i think
the timing was important to show people
that you might have to walk away from
one opportunity or one career but there
is something else out there and i hope
people take some hope um from seeing me
kind of land on my feet so quickly after
the departure from what was really my
dream i'm excited i'm really excited to
work with the daily wire i think we're
going to be able to get into some issues
that are a bit too uh taboo for a lot of
mainstream media outlets espn included i
want to dig into these vaccine mandates
i want to talk to the athletes and
coaches whose lives are being directly
impacted by them and it is a rapidly
changing and evolving landscape and
people are in some precarious positions
um you know you saw what happened at
barclays yesterday with the protests in
support of kyrie irving how accurately
is that being covered how did it
resonate with him um auburn university
you know just announced that they'll be
implementing these federal mandates what
does that do for their football team and
their athletics department we saw what
happened at washington state with nick
rolovich have we really told his side of
the story there's such bias in media
right now against people who are
standing up to these mandates or who are
not complying and i don't feel like
their stories are being accurately told
and i wanna i wanna do that and i'm so
happy for the daily wire and so thankful
to the daily wire that they support that
well that is alison williams brand new
here at daily wire allison we're really
excited about working with you and folks
if you would like to support allison's
work and what we do when we try and
bring people in from the from the cold
after the vocal culture goes after them
then head on over to dailywire.com
subscribe use code do not comply for 25
off allison enjoy mexico and look
forward to working with you
we're in a battle for the culture and
for our values like and subscribe to
help keep our videos on the front line
of the fight and top of your feed